Viruses are essentially protein packages surrounding
genetic material.
They can’t survive without a host, and it’s
debatable whether or not they are even alive.
We don’t have time to get into that argument
here, but what we will do in this video is
examine some of the SARS-CoV-2 proteins—the
virus responsible for the disease COVID-19.
By now, you’ve probably seen many images
like this one—these artistic renderings
of coronaviruses.
Coronaviruses get their name from the spikes
that protrude from the surface of a viral
envelope that sort of resemble a solar corona.
These spikes are actually the proteins that
bind to human cells and allow the virus to
infect them.
Amazingly, we already have a lot of information
about these spike or S-proteins.
The proteins are similar to other members
of the coronaviridae family, so researchers
were able to build on that knowledge and rather
quickly create the structures that we’ll
learn about here.
We’ll begin with a protein structure that
was solved by cryogenic electron microscopy,
or Cryo EM.
If we move from this view looking down at
the viral membrane, the spike protein begins
to appear less triangular, and we can see
it has a roughly cylindrical shape.
Notice that it is heavily glycosylated—during
viral replication, it uses our body’s own
enzymes to covalently attach sugars to asparagine
side chains near the protein surface.
It’s thought that glycosylation plays a
role in protecting the virus against our own
immune system.
As we zoom back out, we’re now looking at
the ribbon diagram of the protein, and if
we color the alpha helices pink and beta sheets
yellow, we see a section of alpha helices
running the length of the spike protein.
For the most part, the beta sheets are concentrated
on this end, which is where the spike protein
fuses with a cell to infect it.
The spike protein is actually made up of three
intertwined chains that have identical amino
acid sequences—each of these chains is called
a protomer.
However, the protomers do not have identical
three-dimensional conformations.
Let’s go back to our original color scheme.
We can see the conformational difference in
the protomers by examining a section of the
spike protein that is critical to the viral
life cycle, the receptor binding domain or
RBD.
The RBD is where this virus binds to an enzyme
on the host cell’s surface, enabling it
to fuse with the cell and transport the viral
genetic material inside.
Two of these RBDs are in a down conformation
in this structure—let’s color these yellow.
However, one of these RBDs is flipped up.
This “up” conformation is higher energy,
poised to bind to the cellular receptor and
result in fusion.
It’s thought that when the spike protein
binds, each of these RBDs shifts into this
less stable “up" conformation.
Our own peptide-bond-breaking enzymes called
proteases can cut the spike protein at specific
sites, and conformational changes in the spike
protein enable fusion to occur.
A different research group published a crystal
structure of just the receptor binding domain
of the spike protein.
We’ll keep the RBD colored white.
In this structure, the RBD is bound to angiotensin-converting
enzyme 2—also called ACE2, which is the
receptor on our cell surface that the coronavirus
binds to cause fusion.
Notice these structures are heavily glycosylated
as well—let’s hide the sugars in this
model, so we can focus in on some of the weak
binding interactions that hold the RBD and
ACE2 together.
For example, we have an extensive hydrogen
bonding network at the RBD-ACE2 interface
involving these two tyrosine residues.
This tyrosine side chain is also hydrogen
bonded to the carbonyl of this asparagine
side chain, which in turn bonds through its
N-H hydrogen atom to the carbonyl of this
glutamine on ACE2.
Moving along the ACE2 alpha helix, we have
a glutamate side chain which is deprotonated
at pH 7.4, and a lysine residue that carries
a positive charge at that pH.
These residues are both involved in hydrogen
bonding with the amide of a glutamine side
chain.
Notice that these hydrogen bonds are relatively
short, owing to the strong hydrogen bonds
that can form when charged amino acid side
chains are involved.
In this region, we have extensive hydrogen
bonding—we see some between amino acid backbone
atoms, and some additional hydrogen bonds
among polar and charged residues, like the
hydrogen bonds of this tyrosine with a negatively
charged glutamate side chain and a positively
charged arginine side chain.
Overall, characterization of the spike protein
is super important because this paves the
way for vaccine development.
If we’re able to prime our immune system
by introducing small, harmless peptides that
resemble the spike protein, our immune system
can recognize and build up antibodies against
it, protecting us against COVID-19 infection
in the future.
Also, knowing what the RBD binds to could
help us develop treatments that tie up the
virus by binding it outside of the cell, before
it is able to fuse and cause infection.
If the virus does undergo fusion, viral genetic
material is released into the cell.
In the case of coronaviruses, this piece of
RNA travels to our own cell’s ribosomes
and hijacks them to create its own viral proteins.
An interesting thing I learned making this
video is that this viral RNA is capable of
shifting the three-letter frame of RNA bases
that is read by the ribosome—this essentially
doubles the peptide sequence that can be made
from one single strand of viral RNA.
Viral translation using our ribosomes makes
the proteins that the virus needs to assemble
additional copies of itself, which will eventually
be released from the cell and infect other
cells.
There’s an important protein that is translated
in this process, and that is the main protease
that cleaves the viral polypeptide chain into
the functional proteins needed to assemble
new viruses.
This is another therapeutic target—if an
individual is already infected with the virus,
but you can administer a drug that binds to
the protease and stops it from creating mature
viral proteins, viral replication can be slowed.
This main SARS-CoV-2 protease is a dimer made
up of two identical protein chains, and it
must dimerize to become a functional protease.
There are many amino acid interactions at
the dimer interface, but the researchers that
published this crystal structure suggest that
the ionic interactions between the side chain
of this arginine residue and this glutamate
drive the dimerization.
This interaction is present on both sides
of the dimer.
Moving over to the active site, the important
residues are this cysteine side chain and
this histidine.
This enzyme is a cysteine protease, so it
uses the nucleophilic cysteine to attack the
amide bond of a peptide.
In the mechanism, the histidine nitrogen grabs
the proton off of cysteine’s side chain,
allowing it to attack the peptide bond.
The peptide bond is cleaved, and then a water
molecule can come in, releasing cysteine so
that the protease can cleave another polypeptide
chain.
Enzymes containing nucleophilic catalytic
residues are excellent targets for irreversible
inhibition.
Because they contain a nucleophilic amino
acid side chain—cysteine in this case—inhibitors
can be designed that bind to the enzyme with
a permanent covalent bond.
Unlike reversible inhibitors that can pop
in and out of an active site, these irreversible—also
called suicide—inhibitors permanently inactivate
the protein, preventing it from doing its
job and creating more viral proteins.
These researchers had previously designed
inhibitors for other coronavirus proteases.
They were able bind to one of these inhibitors
to the active site of the SARS-CoV-2 protease,
and that’s what we’re looking at here.
Notice the serine is clearly involved in a
covalent bond with the ketone of the inhibitor.
Now, this is a reversible reaction, so this
isn’t a suicide inhibitor itself, but I
still think it’s pretty neat to see the
cysteine tied up in a covalent bond in this
active site.
Over here, this carbonyl of the inhibitor
is making hydrogen bonds with three backbone
NH groups of the protein.
The catalytic histidine of the protease is
also involved in a hydrogen bond.
This ring is involved in an extensive hydrogen
bonding network involving both backbone atoms
and side chains.
Knowing the contacts an inhibitor makes with
an enzyme allows chemists and biologists to
consider the interactions and potentially
design even better inhibitors.
Because COVID-19 infection is particularly
harmful to the lungs, this research group
administered the inhibitor directly into the
lungs of mice by inhalation.
The mice did not suffer adverse effects from
this treatment, and so this could potentially
lead to promising COVID-19 treatments in the
future.
Every new piece of information we learn about
viruses leads us to a better understanding
of disease and treatment.
You might be wondering what you can do at
a time like this.
First of all, if videos like this interest
you, keep at it!
Work on your understanding of disease and
structure, so that you can be part of the
cure in the future.
Follow the hygiene and social distancing guidelines,
not only to prevent getting the disease, but
to slow the spread of Covid-19 so we can keep
our researchers and the healthcare workers
on the front lines safe.
And be sure to take care of your own mental
health.
Reach out to friends and family by phone,
text, and video chat.
Spend time on your hobbies—get some exercise.
We’re going to need that awesome brain of
yours in the future, so take good care of
it.